most house fires here residentially they
start in kitchens in fact john
every 18 hours there is a fire here in
southern nevada the american red cross
is launching a new campaign
offering free prevention courses online
to keep you and your home safe we have
hector mejia live this morning in the
far northwest valley with details on
that hyper good morning to you sir
hey there john and alex good morning so
the whole goal this morning is to
prevent
tragedy so we're having a round table
discussion with the american red cross
of southern nevada
we'll talk in a second about their
partnerships but this is cynthia
she's going to talk to us about the new
program it just launched this month
absolutely it's called sound the alarm
it's a campaign
and since it's launched in 2014
we've saved over 850 lives
so it's typical that you know we go into
a home and we install those free
you know smoke alarms but right now due
to covered restrictions
we're doing everything virtually so we
have
you know volunteers who are online ready
to respond
to all of those home fire safety
questions that you have
so it's part of a larger campaign but
now as we adapt to the current times we
have this
uh course that people can watch from
home tell us about the partnership with
las vegas fire and rescue
absolutely so you know we respond to
over 60 000 you know disasters a year
90 of them are home fires and who better
to know that than
our partners you know las vegas fire and
rescue they know
how critical home fire safety is and
that's why tim zamanski is here
to tell us about home fire safety as
well thank you so we want to say hi to
tim good morning
lauren so we have a kitchen you know the
stove right next to you what are some
big takeaways for people at home
to know to prevent those house fires one
of the leading cause of fires in las
vegas and the leading cause of fire
related injuries
thing you want to do is if you have a
pan fire shut off the stove
first to remove the heat take the lid of
a pan
and just put it on there and that's the
best way to put that fire out and you
were telling us earlier what you don't
want to do is
start throwing water at it never throw
water on a grease fire
it will expand 400 times its volume that
means if you throw one bottle of water
on there
you'll get 400 bottles back at you
faster than you can blink your eye and
you'll get severe burns from it
and it's also important to highlight you
know they happen every day and can
happen at any time in fact
uh the fire department had a call
earlier this morning overnight this is
what we call a pot on the stove and we
had one just coming in at three o'clock
in the morning people
says the smoke alarm went off their
apartment was full of smoke
when we got there we found out it was a
a pot that was left on the stove so we
tell people
when you're done cooking for the day in
the evening even if you're tired
take everything and put it in a sink
don't leave anything on the stove
and before you go to bed at night the
last thing you want to do is walk over
to the stove and make sure that all
those burners are off
tim thank you so much for joining us
this early in the morning so
let's go over the website for those
people at home who want to watch the
course
and prevent a house fire absolutely so
you can visit
soundthealarm.org forward slash nevada
and make an appointment there like i
said it takes
20 minutes of your time and we can teach
you all about home fire safety
awesome thank you so much for having us
we'll be posting all of those details on
eightnessnow.com
reporting live from the northwest hector
mejia back to you guys
all right hector thanks so much for